نحاوروا وبنود مهمه على طاوله القاده
والمسؤولين والناشطين في قمه المناخ كوب
27 في شرم الشيخ البند الابرز الخسائر
والاضرار بكل بساطه ان البلدان الاكثر
تضررا من الاحتباس الحراري تطلب مساعده
ماليه للتعامل مع عواقب الفيضانات والجفاف
وغيرها من اثار تغير المناخ هذه التغطيه
تكون لخسائر اقتصاديه مثل المنازل
والاراضي والمزارع والشركات وخسائر وغير
اقتصاديه كموت الناس او خساره المواقع
الثقافيه او فقدان التنوع البيولوجي من
الموضوعات الاساسيه ايضا التي تناقشها
القمه ان يكون التنفيذ هو الهدف الاساسي
اي حان الوقت لتطبيق بنود اتفاق باريس
للمناخ والتعهدات التي جرى التوافق عليها
سابقا كذلك سيركز المجتمعون على تنحيه
الخلافات السياسيه جانبا
بسط تصاعد حده التوترات بين الولايات
المتحده والصين والتصعيد في حرب اوكرانيا
ايضا مناقشه حق الدول الناميه في
الاستمرار في استخدام الوقود الاحفوري
اثناء سعيهم للنمو باعتباره معركه بين
الاهداف المناخيه للدول المتقدمه وحاجات
الدول الناميه للتقدم